dragging my ass out of here own
Christmas the disrespect buddy we got to
take an MVP photo go put on your jersey
Jersey like that hey Lamar you got to
try these
smells let's make this quick I'm on a
minute's restriction unless I decide I'm
not whoa fellas I can't let classic War
on
Christmas we're in what the hell was
that Christmas is a basketball holiday
and for 17 years it's been a LeBron
holiday and we're going to make sure it
stays that way I just started my first
gingerbread cookie person aerica man boy
I'm only here for work young king are
you crying you got a problem cuz
Christmas is an emotional time of
year M that's not how coaches speak to
players in my
league Lamar versus everybody just like
all times KD cut the feed football's
going off the air hang on some kid
online is arguing with me about about
vorp what's the matter you don't run
anymore ah my
really that's the worst fall I've ever
seen please step back you're offside oh
now you tell me Christmas is mine you
can have January do it Lamar they're
basketball players they're cooler than
you yipp Kay Justin
Tucker Happy Trails Braun no more I knew
you were going to do that
now let's celebrate Christmas the right
way ignoring our families by alternating
between football and
[Music]
basketball do you really think you have
a chance to get S Mr cowboy cowboy I was
always kind of partial to the Ravens oh
really I'm a big Browns fan this
week